oh superfoods it seems that in an era of
tick tock the definition has shifted
from pomegranates and blueberries to
influence or endorsed detoxes and
supplements it's no longer enough to
just eat whole fruits and veg we need to
add a bunch of magic elixirs powders and
other expensive ingredients into our
daily routine Tick Tock is full of daily
routines stacked with these influencer
approved extras but are they actually
worth the hype as we like to say there's
a lot to unpack hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
in today's video we'll be taking a look
at some of the hottest Foods in the
influencer wellness scene breaking them
down as usual with science and Sass and
you can pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating and if you guys
are not already subscribed here please
hit that subscribe button and don't
forget to follow me on Tick Tock and
Instagram at Abby's kitchen now I just
want to get something straight here
folks superfood is a marketing term yes
some foods are more nutritionally dense
than others but crowning certain foods
as super suggests that as long as we get
those magical unicorns into the diet
[Music]
but nutrition is actually a long game
it's not about a single food or meal or
day it's about the big picture over time
and the same way no one food can ruin
your health no one food can improve it
either not to mention when we drop the
moral superiority of using the term
superfood we can find better balance
with all foods not just a select few
that said I'm all about taking an
additive approach to eating and I can
appreciate that certain foods and
supplements can help to complement our
health and wellness goals so today I'll
be breaking down the evidence on some of
the most common influencer approved
superfood Trends and whether or not they
help or have the power to harm first off
let's talk about bone broth but all I
know is it's good for your gut health
it's good for your gut lining it's good
for inflammation it keeps inflammation
down and which overall just like will
connect to the health of the rest of
your body go for your hair skin nails so
for anyone who is new to the bone broth
craze it's essentially the aftermath of
slow cooking animal bones and connective
tissue with water and vinegar to produce
a brothy liquid and adding vinegar is
essential to this process because it's
what helps to extract the vitamins and
minerals from the tissue but not all
bone broth is created equal for example
using bone marrow in the preparation
yields a broth that is high in vitamins
A and K as well as minerals like zinc
iron Boron selenium and Omega-3s whereas
connective tissue provides compounds
like glucosamine and chondroitin which
may help to improve joint health as for
the cleans around a bone broth and
improved gut health the research here is
unfortunately limited as we really only
have in vitro and animal research but
the evidence that we do have suggests
that the gelatin in bone broth may help
to improve our gut health by protecting
and healing the gut lining gelatin also
binds to water which may help to move
food through the digestive tract and
improve regularity we also have some
early research linking glutamine which
is an amino acid in gelatin with
improving gut permeability as the
inflammatory effects we do know that the
amino acids in bone broth like Glycine
and Arginine have antioxidant properties
and may therefore provide
anti-inflammatory effects and of course
because bone broth is loaded with
collagen it may also be beneficial for
the Integrity of skin hair and nails and
I'm going to be diving deeper into
collagen in a hot minute so stick around
if you want to hear my thoughts on that
so my hot take is I say bone broth is
definitely worth a go it's rich in
protein and other vitamins and may
provide some health benefits but
ultimately we still need more research
to understand how much we would need to
consume for Better Health next up let's
talk apple cider vinegar it's finally
been 30 days and I am way less bloated
Than I Used to Be I've lost six pounds
and my digestive health is the best it's
ever been okay so weight loss is one of
the most common claims tied to drinking
apple cider vinegar but is it really all
it's cracked up to be well when we look
at the research the evidence is pretty
mixed most research that does link apple
cider vinegar to weight loss seems to
suggest that it likely has to do with
the acetic acid content which appears to
increase feelings of fullness which may
lead to weight loss over time so for
example one small study found that
consuming vinegar with a meal increased
satiety and cause participants to eat
about 250 calories less a day similarly
other Studies have found a modest
increase in weight loss with higher
intakes of apple cider vinegar however
we also know that other vinegars like
red wine vinegar and balsamic vinegar
Ash contain more acetic acid than apple
cider vinegar so in theory we would
likely see the same weight loss results
from using any other vinegar variety
either way most of the studies on apple
cider vinegar and weight loss are very
small short term only show very modest
weight loss and didn't actually look at
drinking apple cider vinegar in
isolation but rather alongside or
immediately after a meal Plus in most
studies participants were also on a
calorie restricted diet so it's really
hard to conclude if the weight loss was
a result of the diet or the apple cider
vinegar or a combination of both on top
of that some research suggests that the
actual reason for a subjective feeling
of fullness after drinking vinegar is
because of its nausea inducing effects
which naturally would reduce the desire
to eat I did not sleep for one second
last night and I cracked the bottom of
the toilet bowl oh God we also want to
be cautious of the frequency of drinking
apple cider vinegar as it can wear away
at our tooth enamel as for the alleged
digestive benefits apple cider vinegar
does contain small amounts of the
Prebiotic fiber pectin which feeds the
good gut bacteria and may help with
regularity Over time however you can
actually get a lot more pectin from just
eating an actual Apple than you would
from taking a shot of apple cider
vinegar now it also does contain some
live bacteria if you're buying the
unpasteurized option but we don't know
what strains a bacteria or if it
contains a clinically significant dose
and spoiler alert it almost certainly
does not it's also acidic so a lot of
folks suggest that it's helpful for
those dealing with low stomach acid
which in turn May again theoretically
reduce bloating but an ounce of vinegar
is literally nothing compared to the two
liters of gastric juices your gut
produces every day so yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
like it's literally a drop in the bucket
not to mention we have much stronger
more evidence-based supplements and
medications that can help with
hypochloremia if that is an issue above
all the alleged benefits I would say
that probably the strongest is that it
may have some benefits for blood sugar
management so hot take care folks again
I don't think apple cider vinegar will
do anything dramatically magical but
because it is inexpensive and may have
some benefits in certain scenarios and
certain populations it may be worth a
try I do not however recommend taking
shots of it thanks to the effect it's
going to have on your teeth so you're
much better off just adding it to salads
or sauces a little more regularly next
up let's talk about greens powders my
hormonal acne has nearly completely gone
my eyes are literally brighter and
whiter I also feel so much less bloated
and way more energy so I actually have a
whole video on greens powders which you
can watch right here for a more in-depth
deep dive but for for today's video
we're going to keep it short and sweet
so generally speaking powdered greens
can contain up to 75 plant-based
ingredients which obviously sounds great
in theory but I do like to think about
greens powders kind of like a
multivitamin that can help to fill in
some nutritional gaps but not as a
replacement for real fruit and veg and
ultimately there's something that greens
powders can do that actual food can't so
if you're already eating a varied diet
then adding greens powders is probably
obsolete but as far as the digestive
health claims go it isn't really black
and white considering just how complex
and individualized gut health really is
so for instance a lot of greens powders
are formulated with gut health
ingredients like digestive enzymes
probiotics prebiotics and fiber but
because our microbiomes are extremely
diverse your digestive system may not
respond the same way to Greens powders
as someone else's for example a lot of
people dealing with digestive issues and
bloating are sensitive to high FODMAP
Foods so greens powders may actually
make your symptoms worse in this case
because they're often loaded with high
FODMAP ingredients like inulin fiber
chicory root extract garlic extract
fructo oligosaccharides Apple powder
asparagus powder and shiitake mushroom
powder it is also important to note that
not all probiotics are made equal as
well so if you're turning two greens
powders to reduce bloating there is a
potential chance that it may contain a
probiotic strain that actually could do
the opposite for you ultimately it
really does come down to trial and error
and find the right product for your
unique needs but again it's absolutely
not a replacement for gut friendly foods
that naturally contain fiber probiotics
and prebiotics as for the claims around
increased energy at best powder greens
only provide like 50 calories per scoop
and calories are the body source of
energy so we wouldn't really be driving
significant and energy from the calories
in Greens powders unless of course we're
mixing it into like a smoothie or juice
sure some powdered greens might contain
caffeine from like green tea extract
which may increase perceived energy
levels but this is really no different
than just drinking a caffeinated
beverage like coffee green tea or matcha
my hot take is if you struggle to get
all the nutrients you need in the day
sure a greens powder like any
multivitamin may help to fill the gaps
but read those ingredients carefully and
pay close attention to your symptoms
when trying them out because ultimately
they can be triggering for some
sensitive folks moving on everyone's
Obsession right now collagen
huh
wait
who
a
so collagen is a protein that is
essential for the structural Integrity
of our skin bones muscle hair and
tendons as we age the production of
collagen declines naturally resulting in
the appearance of fine lines and
wrinkles now we do have quality research
suggesting that collagen supplementation
may help to improve skin elasticity and
this is likely because collagen is rich
in amino acids like hydroxyproline
Proline and glycine which research
suggests are absorbed uniquely as
dipeptides and are key to signaling skin
cell regeneration and hyaluronic acid
synthesis but the million dollar
question
one million dollars
is whether or not consuming collagen is
any better than consuming any other
protein since we know that technically
collagen can be made in-house from the
amino acids in the protein that we eat
as well as from vitamin C and we know
that eating enough protein can also
synthesize dipeptides as well the
research has really only started to dive
into this distinction but we are
definitely left with a lot of questions
for instance one city comparing collagen
to protein did find that participants
taking collagen supplements had
improvements in skin elasticity compared
to folks who just ate the basic protein
diet however the study design wasn't
ideal basically they looked at elderly
patients and gave one collagen and in
the other group they actually lowered
their protein intake to match that of
the collagen group in reality we would
want to see the protein increased
because we're talking about adding a
supplement not replacing Whole Food
protein in the diet the elderly
participants also had protein intakes
way below what we would see in most
health-conscious young adults so yeah
there's a lot of gaps to be filled here
my hot take is that I used to be a lot
more skeptical but I do think we have a
lot more clues now that collagen may be
uniquely beneficial we still have a lot
of unanswered questions namely if we eat
ample protein and not just enough to
read a collagen supplement as well but I
think your best bet would be to choose a
collagen protein that also contains like
whey or pea protein rather than choosing
collagen instead of a higher quality
protein powder or Whole Foods but next
let's talk about the oh so popular CMOS
CMOS has 92 out of 107 minerals that we
need in our body to properly function
and it has literally cleared up my skin
my gut every it's amazing so CMOS is
arguably the newest and hottest
superfood gaining Traction in Wellness
circles with influencers and celebs
singing its Praises for improving skin
increasing libido regulating menstrual
cycles boosting energy the list goes on
and yes CMOS is rich in vitamins
minerals and antioxidants which are
essential to human health but as I said
with greens powders if you're already
eating a balanced and varied diet CMOS
is unlikely to do anything miraculous
for your health that food isn't already
doing it's also worth noting that CMOS
has yet to be FDA approved and there's
very little research to support its
efficacy as to the research that we do
have one animal study found that CMOS
may help to improve gut health and
Immunity in rats due to its Prebiotic
properties and we know that seaweed in
general May benefit gut health as it's
rich in a source of fiber and live
bacteria so any positive effect that
CMOS may have potentially have on our
gut may also translate to improvements
in skin health because skin is a
reflection of our gut and the same thing
goes with immunity because our immune
system is largely housed in the gut
however it's worth noting that there is
a huge variability in nutrition in
cmoses just depending on the environment
in which they were grown and that's true
for all seaweeds and sea vegetables
iodine content in particular can vary
very drastically in seaweeds so you may
potentially be exposed to a larger than
expected dose of iodine which can
negatively impact the thyroid in some
folks there's also the risk of heavy
metal exposure in seaweeds like CMOS
because they tend to absorb heavy metals
in high amounts the toxicity risk does
appear to be low with one study showing
that the heavy metal is absorbed in
eight types of seaweed did not pose
serious risks to health but it's still
really worth pointing this out as I've
seen some folks on Tick Tock
intentionally overdosing on CMOS and
consuming a lot more than what is
indicated which is something I never
advise if supplements work they are not
benign not to mentioned because the
supplement world is the wild west and
there's not a whole lot of Regulation
it's often hard to know exactly what
we're getting and on top of that CMOS
also has a hefty price tag with most
jars ranging from 30 to 40 dollars what
so my hot take is from what I've seen
CMOS isn't the most pleasurable part of
most people's supplement routine and I
don't think that the benefits are so
overwhelming that they justify the price
tag and the daily torture session so I'd
personally stick to a balanced diet and
with evidence-based vitamins probiotics
and Prebiotic supplements that we know
are effective and safe and finally let's
talk about SuperFood mushrooms like
lion's mane I'm not going to tell you
the benefits go and do your research but
here's a little sneak peek and get onto
it so according to this marketing lines
mean is the Holy Grail of Health
supplements as it allegedly helps to
improve everything under the Sun
including energy mood stress immunity
gut health brain health Etc but can One
supplement really do it all the short
answer is
how about new but let's investigate so
like most plantarized substances lion's
mane is rich in antioxidants and
research has shown that it may have some
anti-inflammatory benefits as well but
like I've basically been saying this
whole damn video you don't need to
exclusively get your antioxidant fix
from lion's mane alone or really any
other supplement especially if you're
already eating a diet rich in fruits and
vegetables which contain a lot of
antioxidants now it is true that lion's
mane may be comparatively more
beneficial compared to other mushrooms
with one study suggesting that it had
the fourth highest antioxidant activity
compared to 14 other mushroom species
but again antioxidants are found
abundantly in a variety of other foods
and not just mushrooms now one thing
that may be particularly unique about
lion's mane is the potential benefits
for brain health as we have research
showing that it may help to relieve
anxiety and depression likely because of
some of its anti-inflammatory effects
other research suggests that lion's mane
may protect against Alzheimer's by
preventing neurological damage caused by
plaques which is what accumulates in the
brain with developing Alzheimer's
however the majority of This research
has been done on rats so we don't only
have a clear idea of how this applies to
humans I did find one small human study
which found that taking lines made
supplements for four months improved
mental functioning of older adults who
are diagnosed with cognitive impairment
and basically the cognitive function
declined as soon as the participants
discontinued their use of the supplement
so yes this could become a lifelong
supplement but I would say that's
definitely very promising stuff as for
the immune need boosting claims there is
some research that Lions mean may help
to support immunity by stimulating
activity in the intestine but again this
research was done on animals and we
still need to get more studies out there
to better understand the effective lines
mean on the gut and our immune system
but like I said earlier anything that is
going to be good for the gut will bend
and fit the immune system as they are
intimately connected so my hot take here
is I say that if brain health is a
priority for you it's probably worth a
good try although it's definitely not a
replacement for other brain boosting
behaviors most notably exercise and
Stress Management well I hope that gave
you a little more insight into what
supplements or superfoods are worth a
buy this year for you remember that no
one food or supplement can make or break
your health so the bottom line is to
always focus on the boring basic AKA
balance and on that note that's all that
I have for you guys today if you like
this video please be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
what you'd like to see me talk about
next subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]